you know there are three las vegas
swimmers who are hoping to make waves at
the summer games in tokyo next month
each has a remarkable story as they swam
their way under the u.s team
john treach caught up with each of these
talented ladies who are heading to the
games
they are 15 16 and 20 years old
soaking with hard work and stroking for
history
[Applause]
this is the dream this is what every
swimmer
wants and for me to actually get it and
earn it
it's very like satisfying
katie grimes may have been born in 2006
but she attacked the u.s 800 freestyle
with the talent and tenacity
of an olympic veteran this katie
finished second to only world record
holder katie ledecky and it's easy to
see why
i love when my muscles are in pain
because i know i just got better
i know when he says set the best revenge
is to make it look
easy so i'm like okay let's get this
bella sims began swimming at 10
late to the game but not to start him
the 16 year old is on a 4 by 200 relay
team
and is ready to splash the world with
red white and blue
i got the gear the other day and i was
like oh my gosh
in heaven but yeah
definitely like the just wearing the
flag and like having to represent them
is awesome after not making team usa in
2016.
erica sullivan carried motivation into
every meet
her 2020 olympic dream was stalled but
she never stopped
now erica takes on tokyo i'm very proud
of the growth and
ways i've come in the last three to four
years but i definitely want more i'm not
going to settle
i'm going to try my best and go for a
medal at the games three young women
born and raised in the desert
bringing personality to the pool and the
type of character that makes the country
proud
one of the comments was a lot of
six-year-olds in the nation suddenly
want to move to nevada
welcome to las vegas swim city
john treach hates sports now